what's going on
reject nation it's Greg Alba here with
me today is comedian John Moses do you
like having that be is your leading
comedian John perform for us right now
I'm gonna introduce John to one of my
favorite YouTube channels arts peer
entertainment they do these i trailer
spoofs and light animated format
oh cool awesome and they tell the toon
sandwich series they have to prep John
Moses for this I showed him the to
Justice League trailers because even
though he watches the comic book movies
doesn't really get around to the trailer
so I showed ya two latest Justice League
trailers so he could understand what's
going on I did get to this track after
that's hard prep hard prep isn't it
serious business here I hope you find
this funny cuz you're a comedian
[Music]
and hostage was dead before I got here
okay what did you do this weekend was
there no I did not kill a hostage at the
courthouse whoever told you that they
died I didn't do much either
I might here just look up hey whatever
happened to that guy I don't know I
guess he's through in the cow he's a
no-show now I said the Age of Heroes
would never come again oh they were
clearly wrong I said Age of Heroes not
angel she rose hey it was a significant
period in my life mmm by God
it's come again this is the Chi Rho
Gotham deserves
[Music]
in Steppenwolf
no I'm dropping wolf did you not just
witness my entrance but don't worry
when Steppenwolf gets here
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and everyone's gonna blame Batman for
being a total no show one misses the
days when ones biggest concerns were
exploding wind-up penguins over it
that's still my biggest concern please
don't tell me you stopped the early
river sweets how I know penguins spotted
at 2300 I assure you just because you
can't see them doesn't mean they're not
out there lurking in the dark we are on
a play backwards Alfred take it boy they
found me
this is crazy honestly I think we're all
gonna die does anyone else want to take
a stab at giving the big motivational
speech I don't know either I think it's
gonna feel okay oh yeah I thought you
looked familiar
[Music]
the penalty is every hero's worst
nightmare Superman was a beacon to the
world
well he didn't just say
he killed all his buddies all Angelou
painting I'm fixating on the number
seven for some reason
oh hey pod man thanks for showing up
where have you been the last oh wow they
really just vanished huh oh that's rude
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
he said you come now let's hope you're
not too late hey it's never too late to
give them how what before you arrived
there were two impacts or what happened
did you land twice or something uh yeah
I I did land twice I landed I realized
I'd missed the mark by a few hundred
yards didn't feel like walking so flew
up and landed again a lot closer that's
awkward
yeah it is it's really awkward in fact I
kind of wish I'd mention it moving on I
know it's you should have darling you
sort of landed softly the second time
yeah I should have done a lot of things
so disenchanted landings anyway what's
the point of meeting in secret if you
get a landmark an age oh my god you know
what screw this planet Alfred did that
crazy superhuman from outer space show
up we desperately need his help
I'm terribly sorry uh he's a no-show
I think it is fair to say that I am the
most valuable player on the team but he
has no power so he's out what are you
guys gonna stop holding that over me
flashy super fast something no man
should ever brag about but he has no
skill every time he moves it becomes an
electrical school why can't you be more
like Quicksilver Quicksilver doesn't
need all the zappity zap zip neural
flash and no substance flash Wow I
didn't ask to be so highly charged
cyborg can do some useful things but
he's such a downer honestly his robot
parts are less robotic than his
personality I disagree conversation
terminated and Aquaman he can control
water and fish which would be a real
asset if we weren't fighting on dry land
no one could have predicted that but hey
if any of these aliens set foot on my
home surf they don't be soggy anyway I
think I've made my point so why have you
brought us to Superman's grave Bruce and
why is the coffin out of the ground
because the real MVP did not our IP
that's right everybody I'm back I had to
levitate quite a few dirt particles one
by one but I eventually dug myself out
what'd I miss
it's great to Rebecca narc but there is
something you should know your public
funeral cost American taxpayers over
time there are going to let you do it in
installment for tchen Utley they've kept
your job open at the Daily Planet so uh
where'd he go I think he went back
inside the coffin Clark did you just go
back inside your coffin No
I think that's it what do you think John
Moses comedian it answered a lot of
questions well actually just brought
them up just wondering why is a command
even a thing right now why wouldn't you
just be at the shoreline that was a
great call I'm like two steps think me a
while to get what the joke was when
laughter and shows up he shows up like
in secret and it's like people like
teeth like Tyrannosaurus Rex steps oh
that's it part but then if the joke was
why is the step so heavy on the same so
it maybe makes like one strong landing
that makes sense yeah and in this movie
I mean they they have a hint of him and
that Justice League trailer when there's
like there's no Lantern so there's like
hey team that the lanterns will
important they might make a cameo the
new Green Lantern movie they're working
on is supposedly like their cult like
lethal weapon in space there's gonna be
like two main Green Lantern's oh I think
it's Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart like you
know the Bell Gibson into whoever my
intern basically so one of them was Jon
Stewart's the black Green Lantern yeah
there was a black Green Lantern yeah I
mean I didn't just make that up
no no well there you go no you did not
create the black there's a lot of puns
here a lot of Steppenwolf puns what do
you think man what a horrible name is
like Steppenwolf some demigod yeah 70s
artist I guess like what videos are
gonna get the references yeah all right
that tells you ought to the trailers
yeah I was like Steppenwolf's the
villain you're like you're kidding me
magic I think the animation here is so
fantastic
they look so accurate the churro bit was
great think about like the littlest
things like when Wonder Woman burst
through I love the closing bits when
it's just the dialogue of them talking
in Superman's back thinking about how he
yeah your funeral costs
cost us a lot of money yeah that was a
real watchmen ripoff like remember at
the end of Watchmen dr. Manhattan like
dissipate they think he's dead and he
disappears but he's just on the planet
he has he knows if he has to yeah the
downfall yeah so I feel like they like
stole that from
opaza Watchmen positive yeah like
Superman's dead now Superman's gone and
then he comes back and I wish we watch
the trailer and they teased it I was
like ah man why don't you just leave
something for us to figure out yeah yeah
exciting movie the movies I mean they
revealed that Henry Cavill is bit on set
I just appreciate it but one time you
see him it's not an actual scene it's
like a dream sequence and that one
trailer where Lois is on the farm oh
right yeah yeah I like oh you see him in
the cape and everything right and that
could also explain why he was on set to
begin with if you didn't already know
yeah behind the scenes photos weren't
such major spoilers if they weren't just
so like desperate for that well you
still don't want to see it well then
we're also teasing Superman yeah well
thanks arts for your entertainment for
letting us watch that that was another
there's another job well done
comedian John Moses approves yeah I keep
wanting to call you John Cena you can
subscribe to the real reject subscribe
for these guys while you're at it too
please click that notification bell you
can follow John Moses on Twitter at John
Moses and he has comedian John knows us
on Facebook and Instagram
I like all his photos on Instagram and
throughout most of my life yeah I like
all his bikini shots